in this video I want to talk about one
of the catabolic fates of pyruvate
specifically fermentation so once
pyruvate is made it can go to it can you
know what happens to it it can go to a
variety of places if there is oxygen
available then pyruvate goes to the TCA
cycle which is also known as the Krebs
cycle which is also known as a citric
acid cycle and then after that it would
go to the electron transport ship well
eventually we go to the electron
transport chain in in another form in
the form of NADH is and fadh2 s which
can be reoxidized and make lots of ATP
more on that the details of all that
sort of stuff later but if there's no
oxygen available that's when we have
this thing called fermentation occur now
I'll talk about the purpose of
fermentation just a moment before I go
do that there are two types of
fermentation there's lactate
fermentation which happens in animals
and there's alcohol fermentation which
occurs in yeast so let's talk about
those so now lactate fermentation we
start on with pyruvate right because
this is the catabolic fates of pyruvate
in animals like and including humans
right we have pyruvate um what can
happen is it can be turned into lactate
which is the conjugate base of lactic
acid which many of you may have heard
about in terms of you know stuff that
builds up in your muscles when you get
sore so the enzyme that catalyzes this
step is called lactate dehydrogenase
there we go with that dehydrogenase word
again was over and I think redox
reaction and we're going to pay
attention to what happened here to the
what happened to this molecule what
happened to pyruvate the carboxyl group
stayed the same nothing happened there
the methyl group also stayed the same
the difference is here that this
carbonyl group was turned into an
alcohol and this actually is the example
that I use previously in another video
as an example for oxidation reduction so
this here has two bonds to oxygen here
it only has one bond to oxygen and it
also had gained hydrogen's both of those
things mean this pyruvate was reduced to
lactate
so pyruvate was reduced something must
have been oxidized well probably think
about dehydrogenase in this case what's
happening is we're having an NADH get
oxidized back to nad plus now why do we
do that why is it that we do that the
reason why is because now this NADH this
NADH or Shammi this nad plus sorry this
nad plus can go back and be used in
glycolysis to make more ATP and aerobic
Li right because there um oops because
there's no oxygen right we need to make
this ATP anaerobically now the reason
why we need to regenerate NAD+ this is
actually the purpose of fermentation the
purpose of fermentation is to regenerate
NAD+ because nad plus is a physical
requirement of glycolysis what does that
mean what does that mean to be a
physical requirement of glycolysis well
if there's no oxygen available that
means the only way that we can create
energy is through glycolysis so in
glycolysis if you recall the what ends
up happening is that each time we go
through glycolysis we make we net 2 ATP
in that process we use up an nad plus
and we make an NADH so basically if you
continually have glycolysis running and
running and running and running running
you will take all of your nad plus ha's
and turn them into nadh --is so you
can't have glycolysis keep going if you
don't have any D pluses you need nad
plus s and D plus is a physical
requirement of glycolysis so what
happens with fermentation is it takes
those NADH that you made in glycolysis
and re oxidizes them back into nad plus
so that you can
keep going through glycolysis okay so
the purpose of fermentation is to
regenerate the NAD+ that wake lack
causes can keep going and keep giving
you energy and aerobic Li one thing I'd
like to know is just a sort of fun fact
is that the reason this happens in your
muscles when they when you exercise
anaerobic we lactic acid builds up in
your muscles and that that that pH
change that lower lowered pH is what
causes a muscle soreness at least that's
what I've heard and I think that that is
the case anyway let's move on to
alcoholic fermentation so in yeast
things that actually happens in two
steps and it's a little bit different so
we start off with the pyruvate and we
turn it into acetaldehyde okay
and so what goes on here this methyl
group said is the same this carb
carbonyl group we still have a carbonyl
group here here's an aldehyde here was a
ketone but basically we lost this
carboxyl group this was a three carbon
molecule now we have a two carbon
molecule so we lost this this carboxyl
group here the enzyme that catalyzes
this step is called pyruvate
decarboxylase okay we lose that carboxyl
group how did we lose it well the way we
lost it was as a carbon dioxide or the
way it was lost so um when when yeast
undergo alcoholic fermentation co2 comes
out okay this is actually this process
here is how beer is made so once we have
this acetaldehyde we have this aldehyde
group here this two carbon aldehyde
group we're going to turn it into
ethanol so what's the difference here we
still have this methyl group in this
methyl group here except we turn this
aldehyde into an alcohol so here we had
two bonds to oxygen here we have one
bond to oxygen so acetaldehyde was
reduced right so if it was reduced
something else is oxidized and of course
in this case we the purpose of
fermentation of course is to regenerate
that nad plus so we oxidize
nadh into NAD+ and the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is alcohol
dehydrogenase all right and so that's
basically it notice that in both of
these cases we regenerate NAD+ so that i
can go back through glycolysis again
because physical requirement NAD+ is a
physical requirement of white Hollis's
glycolysis cannot continue if it doesn't
have a supply of nad plus okay so that's
the purpose of fermentation it allows
you to regenerate this stuff so that you
can keep going through by pollicis and
keep making energy and aerobic lee i
hope that was helpful thanks for
watching